gang crime spilling into a peaceful home
and the killing of nine-year-old olivia
ends seven days of horrific events in
liverpool last tuesday 22 year old sam
rimmer was shot dead in the city by
gunmen on electric bikes then on sunday
twenty-eight-year-old ashley dale was
also shot dead at her home in what
police say was a case of mistaken
identity seven years after her teenage
brother died in similar circumstances
lewis dunn was killed by a gang who
mistook him for a rival
youth worker paul walmsley runs the
lewis dunn foundation and a community
project called nobody left behind
we have to come together as a community
as an area
you know be a voice for this you know it
cannot go unnoticed it cannot just be
another incident that we just carry on
our lives
olivia's death happened on the 15-year
anniversary of liverpool's other
notorious shooting eleven-year-old rhys
jones caught in the crossfire of a turf
war between rival gangs
alan walsh who runs a youth boxing club
says there needs to be a joined up
approach to gang crime
we're all doing a little bit continue
funding them people to do them little
bits but have a overall strategic view
on what we're doing i don't think the
government's doing much about it and i
don't want to make this well it is a
political thing we can't get away from
it i don't think they know what to do
with it i think they think well you know
what let's just hope it dies out itself
and it's not dying out it won't die
in england and wales gun crime has been
falling but here in merseyside it's up
50 percent this year and nationally gun
related deaths are at a nine year high
a lot of it relating to criminal
networks run by remote business-minded
drug lords who are cashing in on all the
misery
come to the door now
just come to the door on a dawn raid
this morning at the other end of the
country officers from the national crime
agency were pulling at the roots of this
problem
the suspect being arrested is an alleged
kingpin drug importer who's also facing
gun allegations after online messages
were decrypted in an international
operation so you don't have to say
anything but it may harm me defense if
you don't mention one question something
which you're late to align in court
the national crime agency conducting
this operation is concerned that one
inevitable consequence of the war in
ukraine is that more guns are available
to criminals
watching the operation on the suburban
streets in surrey was the home secretary
this day was coming right yeah well
she told me her key focus in office had
been tackling gangs and violence
i've made the big changes around stop
and search to give the police the
ability more freedom and flexibility and
powers to apply stop and search but also
when you look at the work that we've
done with serious violence reduction
units the funding that we put into every
police force grip funding so we can
target hot spots that that is working
that is making a difference
but in liverpool's youth organizations
they want a greater focus on young
people and how to offer them an
alternative to gang life
jason farrell sky news